[Music]  you ain't got nothing to bet with care  to make a wager on that bet 50 bucks  says I'll reach the bottom for you $100  minimum bet table I bet you $100 I'll  give you $200  whoever touches got strippers how about  $500 there's pee in that pool I suppose  you wouldn't care - I'll raise - mm I  bet his poop smells like sandalwood what  a bet  all in black always bet on black all I  know is never bet on the white guy I bet  your number I'll make you a little bet  three times 35 is 105 but your hundred  and five thousand dollars you go to  sleep before I do make it a million tell  you the allenburys  has bet his pinky willing to bet my life  if someone were taking bets on your  father's bout with death I'd bet  everything I own on death  [Music]